d'accord robert louis dreyfus alors dans
cette affaire est ce que finalement vous
ai pas le sentiment d'être un peu un
gosse de riche qui s'est fait plumer par
l'om
non parce que gosse de riche je l'étais
m'enfin c'est pas là j'ai jamais mes
parents m'ont jamais d'argent alors donc
j'ai pas de problème là dessus de cette
fumée non parce qu'il ya des ja to man a
une valeur et puis un plaisir
donc ça vaut ce plaisir vous regrettez
pas non pas du tout c'était à refaire je
ferais tu ferais peut-être moins
d'erreurs parce que j'aurais appris
quelque chose
ouais bon allez je n'allais jamais dû
faire de politique pas parler de la
période lui présenter collaro show là
oui les emails de l'étranger